in the last video we learned that if you
just leave water to itself it auto
ionizes so let me say i have two
molecules of water there's some
probability and it's an equilibrium that
one of the hydrogens on one of the
waters bumps off and just joins the
other one so you could end up with a
hydronium
ion it's an ion because it has an extra
hydrogen so i'll put a plus charge there
and obviously everything in here is in
an aqueous solution i could write
aqueous
everywhere a q you could write aq it's
kind of obvious water is obviously in an
aqueous solution it's obviously
dissolved in water
and then plus a hydroxide ion
this is the water molecule that lost its
its its hydrogen atom or its proton
because we know that a hydrogen atom or
at least a hydrogen ion if you get rid
of its electron all you have left is a
proton and that's also an aqueous
solution
and we learned that people really care
and we learned about the equilibrium
constant of this reaction and we also
learned that people really care about
the concentration of this right here the
hydronium or sometimes and let me write
this again because this is actually what
happens and i went over this in the last
video but sometimes the same exact
auto ionization reaction will be written
like this
h2o
disassociating in itself really into
a hydrogen ion in an aqueous solution
plus a hydroxide
anion an aqueous solution or a negative
ion these are the same thing and i write
this way because this is actually the
state that happens that you don't
actually have these protons just
independently they actually do join onto
another water molecule and form a
hydronium ion but these are the same
these are the same exact concept but we
learned in the last video that people
really care about the concentration of
you could pick one of these two they
normally write this one right here
so people really care about the
concentration of hydrogen
of your hydrogen ions and we learned in
the last video that just pure water at
25 degrees celsius which is room
temperature
so let me write that at 25 degrees
celsius the concentration of of of your
of your hydrogen protons because that's
really what they are hydrogen ions is 10
to the minus
7 molar and then we even said hey you
know people don't like to chemists for
whatever reason don't like dealing with
negative exponents so they defined the
ph
the ph
is equal to
the minus
log base 10 of your hydrogen
concentration
of your hydrogen concentration and of
course that's equal to
minus log
base 10
of
10 to the minus 7 for pure water at 25
degrees which is
equal to
7 fair enough
and you could probably imagine if people
took the trouble of
constructing this ph thing and saying
it's a negative log they must really
care about what the hydrogen
concentration of water is and it does
matter you know in a whole bunch of
especially actually biological systems
all the time people worry about the ph
of this or that and obviously i talked
in the last video about ph balance
cosmetics they they're essentially all
sorts of bad things might happen to your
skin if the ph of the cosmetic is
different than your skin i don't know if
that's a fact but i guess that's the
that's the theory behind it so there's
obviously things in the world that
change the hydrogen concentration that
changed this concentration so when we
learned about le chatelier's principle
we said hey you know if we if we maybe
if we add more hydrogen on this side the
equilibrium will change and this
concentration will go up and so we would
have more hydrogen concentration i guess
on the other side you could add more
hydroxide and then you you would you
would have more oh concentration maybe a
little less hydrogen concentration
so if you if you care about things that
are going to do that to this reaction
you probably want to have a name for
them
and the name for them
is acids and bases and i'm sure you've
heard both of these words before
so acids let me write them both down
acids
acid
and
base
now just to you know over complicate
your life a little bit more there are
actually multiple definitions of an acid
and multiple definitions of a base and
they kind of become more and more broad
in what they and what they imply the the
definition that you're probably going to
use the most and the definition that i
always use in my head whenever someone
says an acid is
it increases
hydrogen concentration
when you place it in water when you in
water
in water
and a base is something that increases
that increases
your hydroxide concentration
in water
this is the definition that you're
probably going to see in 90 especially
in a first year chemistry class and this
is called the arrhenius acid or base
let me hope i get his spelling right you
should never take any of the my spelling
words uh at face value you should look
them up because
i'm clearly not a master speller
arrhenius
arrhenius with an h
these are arrhenius acid arrhenius base
so for example if i were to take
if i were to let me give you an example
if i were to take some
hydrochloric acid that's actually what
it's called but you could say hydrogen
chloride in an aqueous solution
it actually disassociates completely
this is not an equilibrium reaction so
let me put it in
this nice well let me use a bolder color
this nice one-way arrow which says hey
this isn't one of these wishy-washy
reactions that go in both directions
this is a this is a strong acid it
completely disassociates in water into
let me put the hydrogen in a different
color
it completely disassociates in water
into a
hydrogen ion an aqueous
solution
plus
chloride plus just a chloride negative
ion in aqueous solution and they just
float in there so you could imagine if
you place hydrogen chloride in water
you're going to increase its its overall
hydrogen concentration and the same
exact reaction could have been written
like this just to hit the point home
hydrogen
chloride and an aqueous
aqueous solution and then you could say
plus
h let me do a different color plus
h2o
it's a one-way reaction
it's a one-way reaction and then you end
up with and i think you understand you
have
h
obviously not all three of them are
h3
oh it's too dark
h3o
plus it donated its hydrogen proton to
that to this water molecule
and then you have plus
the chloride anion in an aqueous
solution
and these this these acids that
completely disassociate in future videos
we're going to look at ones that don't
that are a little bit more wishy-washy
that don't completely disassociate but
these acids that completely disassociate
are called strong acids
and you know strong isn't just you know
just a nice word that they use in
chemistry it literally means
when someone says a strong acid
something that completely dissociates
into water it's a one-way reaction
and all of the strong acids and you
could probably even guess based on on
their chemical makeup but hydrochloric
acid is one of them
you also have you know hydrogen bromide
another strong acid hydrogen iodide
hydrogen iodide you have nitric acid i
think i showed you that in a previous
all of these when you when you put them
into water they're just going to this
little h is going to pop off you join
another water molecule form hydronium
and then this molecule right here
in these cases these are well in the
case of chloride or iodide these are
these are halogens but they're going to
go and form negative ions whatever's
left over
nitric acid then you have sulfuric acid
you've probably heard of that very
strong acid
sulfuric acid and then perchloric acid
these are the strong acids
o4 and these are good to know because if
you see them on a chemistry exam you
know that these are going to completely
disassociate and remember you know we
keep using this word acid what does acid
mean it means that these are strong
acids these completely disassociate and
if you if you
like arrhenius's definition of what an
acid is
they increase your hydrogen
concentration because you're obviously
when you throw this in some water all of
these all of these new hydronium ions
are going to be formed and they're going
to overall increase your your
concentration of them and that's why
they're called an acid
and now if you went on this on the
strong base side
by arrhenius definition right by
arrhenius definition a base is something
that creates
is something that creates hydroxide ions
or anions in water
so pretty much anything if you look at
the periodic table
anything here any of your group one
elements and group one elements your
alkali earth metals
your alkali earth metals it's bonded
with hydroxide
if you put them in water the hydroxide
pops off so let me just do with lithium
or sodium
so for example these are strong bases so
if i take some
if i take some lithium
let me do nice
lithium hydroxide
in an aqueous solution
aqueous solution this is a this
completely disassociates completely
disassociates no equilibrium here just
it's a this is a strong base so what's
it going to disassociate to well the
little hydroxide ion is going to pop off
that's going to be a minus it's in water
still
plus
a lithium
a lithium ion
right there
so this will always disassociate in
water the same thing as if you have if
you have sodium
if you have sodium
sodium is going to do the same thing
sodium hydroxide and aqueous solution
one-way reaction you produce hydroxide
and some
sodium cations and so you imagine when
you put these in water this
concentration is going to go up it's
just like what we did in the chatelier's
principle where you know we said oh what
if you add some of this or some of that
to an equilibrium reaction well how do
you add it well in this case you can add
a strong acid or a strong base now
everything i've done so far this is the
arrhenius definition where an acid
increases your hydrogen concentration a
base
increases your hydroxide concentration
now that is what you're what you're
going to see 90 of the time but there's
a slightly broader definition out there
and that is the and i don't know the
correct you know i always say just
bronstead but
if you don't have fancy fonts it's
spelled like this bronstead
lowry
acid
acid or base and i'll say and but you
know if you if you have good fonts
there's usually this little cross
cross in the o so i don't i mean
brunstead bronstead well bronsted-lowry
acid and all of these would also be
bronsted-lowry acid but but the the
broadening of the definition is an acid
is a proton donor proton donor
and a base
a base
is a proton
proton
acceptor
acceptor so let's look at this
definition and in the context of
everything we've just done so far so
if you lift by the bronsted-lowry
definition what is a proton donor here
well this hydrochloric acid it is let me
look at this reaction right here this
hydrochloric acid is donating a proton
to this water molecule right the proton
a hydrogen atom is just a proton that's
an important thing to remember because
it had
a hydrogen ion because if you get rid of
its electron it has no neutron it's just
a proton sitting and sitting in space so
this hydrochloric acid is donating a
proton to this water molecule to make a
hydronium molecule and it gave it away
so this is a bronsted lowry acid as well
just as it was an arrhenius acid
let's see the brownsted
lowry version of a base
okay a base is someone who
proton acceptor
so this guy he was he had this nice
little relationship with this hydroxide
ion this the hydroxide ion got
disassociated so you can kind of and it
becomes a little bit fungi fungible
right here you can kind of say hey this
guy accepted
accepted this positive charge or he was
and i you know it's a little bit
wishy-washy here because this this isn't
uh you know it's not like this someone
gave it a proton you can kind of think
it as he actually gave away electrons
but
you know if you just look at the the
final practice okay he's got he's got a
positive charge when everything was done
so you say okay maybe that's a bronsted
lowry uh a bronsted lowry base
now you're saying okay well why did
people even make the the trouble of
defining a bronsted-lowry base when you
know all of the arrhenius acids and
bases could also be bronsted-lowry and
well that's because arrhenius is always
you're always dealing with water
everything's in an aqueous solution but
i drew an example here of a
bronsted-lowry base it doesn't have to
be an aqueous solution so if you have
acetic acid right here that's what's in
vinegar plus ammonia
there's there doesn't have to be an
aqueous solution what happens this
hydrogen gets donated to the ammonia ion
to make ammonium so this becomes
positive becomes negative it donated
this electron this proton
right and arrhenius has nothing to say
for this he he because everything he
deals with is hydronium and water but
the bronsted-lowry definition works in
this situation
now the last kind of or the broadest
definition although you know there are
all these definitions but you're going
to be ninety percent of the time good if
you just know the arrhenius definition
and just know that bronsted-lowry and
and what i'm about to say right now also
exists and that's lewis acid and bases
lewis acid and bases the acid now lewis
cares about electrons bronsted-lowry
cared about protons
so lewis instead of saying an acid is a
proton donor
they a lewis acid says it's an electron
acceptor
electron acceptor
and a base is an electron
electron
donor now let's look at in the context
of everything we've done so far
so
elect if if this is really an acid it
should be a electron acceptor and the
way you can kind of think of it is you
had hydrochloric acid before when this
guy gave away
his when he gave away this
this atom or this this proton right
there he kind of kept his electron so he
was kind of an electron acceptor it's a
little bit it's a little bit gray area
there i mean it's not like he took an
electron from somebody else but this
would be considered still a lewis acid
and if you think about a lewis base
a lewis base is what it's an electron
donor
right
a lewis base is an electron
donor
so if you have it right here
loose base is an electron donor this
lithium hydroxide when it goes into
water there's a couple of ways to think
of it you can say hey it's donating this
o-h which has these two extra these two
extra these true extra or these this
negative charge so it's an electron
donor i don't like it's kind of squishy
that way so i'm not a big fan of it of
that definition i in my mind arrhenius
makes the most sense and it's kind of
the purest thing are you creating
hydronium or not or are you creating
hydroxide or not but just to just to
show that the lewis the lewis acid-base
definition is the broadest definition
here's a case of a lewis
acid-base reaction that is that is that
that would not be considered either a
bronsted-lowry or an arrhenius base
because this doesn't have to happen in
water and what you have here is boron
trifluoride with a fluoride anion it has
a negative charge it has this little
extra electron here in this situation
this fluoride right here or this this
this floor this fluorine
anion can donate these two electrons so
we could let's say that this this
this one right here is this one right
here and what it does is it donates
these two electrons
to this boron complex right here and so
if it's the electron donor
what is it the fluoride is the base
so this is the lewis
lewis base
and then the electron acceptor is a
lewis acid so this right here is the
lewis acid
lewis acid it's good to know that these
definitions exist and especially if you
don't get so you don't get confused in
the future but for first year chemistry
class if you know the arrhenius
definition really well that's the one
that's gonna that's you'll you'll do
very very well and frankly in my mind
that's the easiest one to contemplate
and that's the one that's going to
matter in most of the the reactions
where you deal with the changes in ph to
water because that's what all the acids
and bases do especially in the arrhenius
case anyway see in the next video and
we'll actually do some math figuring out
the changes in ph due to some acid